la contre-offensive ukrainienne
maintient une pression constante sur la
ligne de front dans la région de Herson
seul grande capitale du Sud dont la
Russie s'étamparée depuis le début de la
guerre
raconte que son unité combat 2 à 3 fois
par jour en tirant toutes les munitions
dans tes disposent
aujourd'hui Moscou a fait marche arrière
[Musique]
a exposé la situation dans Herson et a
proposé que l'armée se cantonne sur la
rive gauche du fleuve nietre le retrait
est ordonné par le ministre de la
Défense Sergueï
ce qui était un avantage stratégique
d'avoir cette capitale-là maintenant ne
fait plus de sens on sait qu'ils ont eu
énormément de difficultés à faire des
franchissements d'obstacles surtout sur
la rivière ni pro à chaque fois ils ont
réellement réduit en miettes lors de
leur tentative de franchissement
d'obstacles
on repli que le président
ukrainien zellinski prend avec beaucoup
de prudence dans son message quotidien
sur sa chaîne télégram il ajoute que
l'ennemi ne leur fait pas de cadeau et
ne manifestent pas de gestes de bonne
volonté
les Russes ont expliqué le retranchement
par un problème de ravitaillement
est encore fait pour une campagne éclair
alors que présentement ils ont
incapables réellement de se concentrer
dans un seul secteur qui a besoin
réellement d'être réapprovisionné
quotidiennement le soutien logistique et
en matière de renseignement des
États-Unis et de l'OTAN rendent
l'offensif russe laborieuse
Poutine gagne en Ukraine ce sera
désastreux pour les ukrainiens et nous
rendrait également plus vulnérable
si la victoire de l'Ukraine à Herson se
confirme elle portera un coup dur à la
Russie qui avait annoncé en grande pompe
l'annexion de la région il y a à peine
quelques semaines ici Yasmine Khayat
Radio-Canada Montréal